we've been working with women you
memorize defenders for a longest of time
we know the threats they are under and
it's not getting better although it
should there are some good words on
papers in different ways but it doesn't
really change how it is for the women on
the ground sometimes it is enough hell
if delegations high-level delegations
actually meet them in the countries they
are made visible it looks like they have
friends in high places which makes it
more dangerous to get rid of them that
is one thing invite them make sure that
they are included when you talk about
what is needed their voices need to be
heard I was based in Syria until 2012
when I had to skip the country because i
was working with a media center and
Syrian regime attacked the office and
arrested everybody there and I was the
only survivor so I went to Lebanon from
Lebanon I went to Paris and so far two
years and three months i have been an
exiled activist and france the challenge
on the woman is really huge because of
women as a human rights defender she
needs to defend her rights and other
rights and not just to be the defender
and that's it and it's a huge work
freedom is something that I will never
give it up never never because I do
enjoy it even with the pain that I was
in all through even with the bay that I
know Michael Lee's have been through I
know that my supervisor right now she
still kidnap no one knows where she had
and I'm sure that she's enjoying and how
come I with it also enjoying this
freedom it's a battle and Pakistan we
held you lost very good loss but and
closes but the problem is that there is
no implementation of these laws and
tribal region
if I say an education there is very low
education ratio and fatter there is only
three percent education of women and the
FATA and the school has been demolished
by the militants because they don't want
it female come to get educate and they
think that F they will get education so
next they will ask for their rights I am
here to please in the name of Afghan
women to say first of all the issue of
women is a political issue we know it
it's not only about development issues
it's a political issue now is the future
of Afghan women on the table of
negotiations with the Taliban or not we
would like to start getting a clear
answer to this we need to develop and to
develop exchange between women from
leaders from these countries and women
leaders here we don't have this enough I
was confronted with simply with a
Palestinian woman leader of a political
party what did not know Tunisian women
leader of a political party so how can
we help them to develop their own
strategy within their countries that
don't have a possibility to exchange we
hear this again and again delegations
are not aware of the guidelines so
distant that and i think this we have
very much take into account and the
number of measures have been taken to
address this of course i cannot not tell
you that in every third country they
know everything about this but certain
mechanisms has been have been put in
place particularly through the strategic
framework in action been on human rights
at up to two years ago to go in that to
make some significant progress in that
direction
it's not about creating new rights or a
privileged category within the human
right defenders at large as some claim
it's about ensuring that people who
actually face extraordinary challenges
and threats they receive the adequate
protection to keep fighting for their
rights